time off in a good way like this this is
the game that I put that right where you
need to be
yeah you take a little bit and then
traveling do a lot of traveling so the
kids the first two games and just like
we could be four in two easy but be been
doing good yeah and getting the guys
right yeah yeah yeah exactly
Comfort comfort level and you know you
could have one that's like they just
played her a little bit
so you get let's say you get these three
I mean now the whole story change the
whole story is gonna change that'll be
cool yeah stop this little something
right here DeMarcus Ware here on the
Rich Eisen show once again how are you
DeMarcus Ware hey doing great how are
you doing I am doing fine we just saw
you going up to Elway before the game
and man that just didn't work out well
Thursday night I know it you know what
it did man it didn't work out and you
know guys always go into the games like
really optimistic right I mean they you
know talking to early on the sidelines
that's like that grind right it was a
Thursday night game the guys were really
excited I can see how a bond came out
they were very very focused I was
talking about that quiet confidence that
they can going into the game but it was
just too many mistakes and you know what
happens when you have what six or seven
sacks giving up and three forced fumbles
it'll go it'll go south pretty darn fast
the issue is though DeMarcus is
obviously do they are the right
quarterback do they have do they have a
plan to have the right quarterback I
think I think they have the right
quarterback but you have to be able to
protect them think about when the homes
went down you got Matt Moore went into
the game and I'm on the sideline and I
can see Derek Wolfe right I can see Von
Miller licking their chops but they
still didn't get any pressure on those
guys in those situations I don't Matt
Moore he's a seasoned vet nomads been
playing for the Dallas Cowboys and
Carolina Panthers and played very well
so he knew what he was getting into
we're getting the ball off fast right so
they couldn't get any pressure on them
but from an offensive standpoint I'm
like okay you have to protect Flacco
every single time he dropped back even
if they had a defensive let me say I'd
in or are running back in the game
chipping those outside linebacker
defensive end they still were getting
pressure they were getting sex every
single down and it was one of those
things that I've never seen before in my
life and even like from the guys
blitzing in the middle they were letting
some of those guys though so I'm like
there has to be some type of protection
issues that have to be evaluated for
these these mix it up and coming week
DeMarcus Ware here on the Rich Eisen
show twelve seasons in the NFL DeMarcus
and on also you're the greatest player
in the history of Troy football which I
learned I knew had to call you way way
long ago when I used that term for OC
you manyara and I heard from you I heard
from you directly don't don't do that
again
so I I repay in kind here over a decade
later have you ever seen somebody have
their knee rearranged on a quarterback
sneak before asthma Holmes did that
night have you ever say I have I have
never but that's the thing you don't
want the quarterback to really you know
get into the trenches like that you got
those a big offensive line six foot five
360 pounds and it takes just a little
bit of weight of those guys that really
just hunker down on the guy at the hurt
you know you know my homes like that but
the thing is he's one of those tough
quarterbacks you can see him throwing
the ball at his left hand running the
ball a lot so you think that he's
elastic like just like a running back
foot they can't take the pounding as a
running back or take and it's a hard
thing to see what was it like when that
happened hot you know it was a quiet
silence in the stadium because it was
first of all like a sense of hope like
oh my god you know my homes went down on
a big Thursday night game we have an
opportunity to win but then you can see
like the fan thing okay one of the best
guys in the NFL just got injured and
when you see him walk off the field
which is so great about the 12th man in
any team to actually applaud it like
okay I'm glad he's okay he's going to be
able to come back it's not like a maybe
a season-ending injury even though your
opposing team
it was a hard thing to see and uh you
know hopes he hopes he gets well so
really soon
DeMarcus we're here on the Rich Eisen
showing than last thing on on Denver
Emanuel Sanders is now a 49er in Elway
essentially said he didn't like some
things we didn't like some things did
you get any sense of that when you saw
him last week I didn't when I was on the
sidelines talking to him he was very
enthused and he said I'm just coming off
of a big injury my body feels great I
think he had two or three awesome
catches across the middle this way he do
very well and I felt like I wouldn't
ever think that he was going to get
traded because he was one of the more
consistent guys catching the ball that
week even though they had that big loss
and all of a sudden the week after that
he gets traded so I just feel like now
the San Francisco 49ers they just got
better
I think they're one of the still
undefeated teams and they're gonna
really start steamrolling well I mean we
add DeForest Buckner on the show
yesterday I mean that that front line
maybe the best in football would you
agree with that I have been watching
them and just to be too nasty that they
play with I mean just the outside guys
being able to push the pocket the inside
guys being able to you know put the
quarterback in the phone booth so if he
can't make any passes that's what you
want from any type of defense but what's
really great is that you know the
outside not outside linebacker but those
inside linebackers in the corners those
guys come up and hit on those screen
plays they are having great coverage so
those guys out front can get there and
they're stopping the run they are
controlling the line of scrimmage and
they're playing their best defense
because when their coach on the sideline
when they look at that guy how enthused
he is when he makes you know just those
big gestures it's just great to see and
it makes those guys want to play for
DeMarcus Ware here on the Rich Eisen
show you know as well as anybody
DeMarcus that the Broncos are and their
fans and that organization is not used
to consecutive seasons of losing they're
just not used to it it just doesn't
happen
how is Von Miller handling all this when
you when you chatted with him for the
garage you know it's hard because you
know bond it's like I'm going to do what
I need to do as
visual player and trying to leave the
guys and keep them enthused because I
can't see I don't want the guys to see
my morale down at all I want them to see
that I'm in do is to get out hand play
even though our season isn't going like
it should and that's what champions do I
told them you need to put the team on
your back let your motivation sort of
prepare those guys to do better than
what they're doing because you're that
leader that they're gonna look up to and
talking to him at the Dallas Cowboys
game he came down to the game it was
there by week we sat down and chatted
chatted just about how things should go
forward and what he should do and I mean
she's still excited about the season he
was like DeMarcus I need to you know I
need to pick up my pieces because I
haven't been getting the pressure like I
need to and I will really get everything
going this week yeah I mean he's got a
Miss Chubb that was a huge injury oh man
yeah yeah just job he was that Childers
would like that guy when I came in that
right hand didn't able to get pressure
on the quarterback but that power guy so
now when you have that power guy coming
from the right side Vaughn it can easily
use his speed to get around the corner
to create those big plays and now that
guy's in there so that's missing for him
and now he's getting a lot more chips
from tight ends and running backs but at
the end of the day he has a great
defensive coordinator actually head
coach with Vic Fangio they can move them
around put him in the middle put him on
the right in the left and so he can
still make plays and then one another
another person we're gonna see you chat
with tonight on the ground is Peyton
Manning you saw him on the sideline
before the game any sense of what he
wants to do with his life and career cuz
you know there in Denver we had we had
my kiss love of the Denver Post on this
week he would love to see Peyton
basically running the team DeMarcus what
do you think I think hey I think Payne
is one of those guys that if he can be
part of an organization he would bring
in that championship mentality that
they're noble mentality that's how he
played the game he was a sheriff and he
was and I was a deputy
it was just a great opportunity just to
play with him and I think that you know
for his career he's doing what he do
best and that be a personality and he
you can see how Grady's been doing on
his show but for him to be an owner or
like a general manager or to be part of
a team it will be a big turnaround
because he will go ahead and do it the
right way I don't wanna put you into
toughest spot but do you think Denver
needs that right now
you think the Broncos need that I don't
I don't know if the Broncos need that I
just know they need to protect the
quarterback for sure have a sound like
but I know that Peyton coming in and
helping out the whole organization I
think that would be a great DeMarcus
Ware here on the Rich Eisen show which
is the real cowboys team when we saw
this this weekend or the one that is
gonna have struggles up and down over a
three week stretch and have trouble
given Jerry Jones what he wants what do
you think DeMarcus if they can play like
they played this weekend this is how
they play the first weekend yep you know
they can be consistent with running the
football right making those defenses
down the field in the defense getting
those big plays oh yeah you know in the
office not being able to run the ball on
them that's what you want to see that's
that championship team if they can play
that way
every single week they're a championship
contender but it's like can we get that
consistency every single week not just
because the coach said we're going to go
and win the game can you now bow him and
you want that game for your team now
what is going to be that fire for these
Knicks up and coming weeks they're going
to get you to play the same way but
explain to me how how a team can be so
Jekyll and Hyde I mean how does that
happen where where I understand the
first three weeks they did play some
subpar competition which is why the next
three weeks a lot of folks thought was
that's the real cowboys team how does a
team miss the opportunity of taking care
of business against the Saints with
Teddy Bridgewater in his first home
start and then Green Bay without Davante
Adams and then obviously the Jets which
is the same team we just saw gets doing
that how does that happen you know you
see a lot of teams when they're when the
pressure is on them they can really
turn up the heat and get everything
going but the great teams they keep it
going when they play teams that should
be underneath them and that they should
win but they play to their level and
sometimes the Dallas Cowboys they do
that they play to that team's level when
all of the talent that's on the team no
matter if Chiron Smith is out or Collins
is out or you know any of those guys if
they're I still don't matter because the
second guy is coming in will be a
starter on another team so the Dallas
Cowboys from me if they play
consistently like every week of they're
playing the Saints heart they're playing
Billy are the NFC East team the sky's
the limit
ask the poll question of DeMarcus Ware
before we send him on into his day and
we see him tonight on the grind on epics
or to get over there Chris DeMarcus who
do you think has the best shot at
knocking off the Patriots in the AFC
Bills Chiefs Colts Ravens I would say
the bills and that's that's the weirdest
thing because their defense plays to a
point to where they make the team under
one-dimensional because they always make
them I have to pass the football Dale
great run defense from what I've seen so
I would say the bills and their
contender right now man they flipped and
turned everything around and they've
been playing really well
well the I'll bite on this here they're
gonna have to I mean the Patriots the
way that they're playing the way that
are looking they get they get sanu we're
assuming Gordon's going to come back
healthy and and Brady's gonna have as
much as his disposal as possible I'm
hearing rumors that they might even be
still in the market for a much bigger
fish on an in in in the the trade market
how can the bills stay close enough with
New England and maybe even just take him
out in division or win a playoff game on
the road and then get there for a
divisional playoff game and take care of
the Patriots that's the way that they
would actually have to take care of them
thing is when you think about as you get
later on in the season yeah you know you
got injuries right you have but every
single one of those game
at the end it's like the team that wants
the most but the team is also going to
play the best and don't have as many
mistakes I haven't seen a lot of
mistakes from the bills and usually they
play a man on man type mentality my man
is going to be yours almost like Bill
Parcells he's it's gonna be steak and
potatoes type offense taking potatoes
type defense but then it's I'm gonna
wind you down all the way to the end of
the game in this house that chess match
that Bill Belichick they play all the
time so though that's one of those type
teams that can play with the Patriots
that's why I say that it's because they
you're not going to just go in and score
a whole bunch of points off they're
gonna keep the game very close we want
to run the football and then who makes
the best decisions at the end of the
game's gonna win and they can DeMarcus
I love our chats I mean the last time we
talked and he told us about about Jerry
Jones lighting a votive candle and
trying to close negotiations with the
players who he wants to sign I mean yes
I love that story yes one of my favorite
sources mine this show has been great
this this behind the scenes where you
can talk to the general managers the
owners be in the locker room and
actually getting the guys to talk and
open up that it's amazing just what
you're just doing with this show and
just a whole the whole spiel and it's
great to be poor I mean NFL Films and
epics they're there they're the ones
behind it I'm just I'm just fronting it
apart what's your part of epics epics is
they they are the front-runners for sure
yeah and I hope you're gonna do it again
right you want to keep doing all for
sure yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna do the
later on in the seat and I look forward
to working with excellent right back at
you all right - Marcus take care of all
chat soon all right DeMarcus Ware at
DeMarcus Ware on Twitter and Instagram
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app